[Music]
space invasion
big car chase
truth be told I was ready to hang it up
to let miss you today
[Music]
Thanks time
mark 6 front and center
so this implies a theoretical animal not
currently found on the periodic table I
think I will run a simulation to check
element viability yeah listen you have a
ball with that I know it's gonna work
miss take a shower
tap the Oracle grid and some stuff out
of storage come everything from projects
Pegasus Exodus and Goliath get ready for
a major remodel back in hardware mode
hey everybody its charlie if you guys
didn't see marvel dropped a new teaser
and a promo for Captain Marvel just to
celebrate the election day so there's a
whole bunch of new Easter eggs some of
them really funny some of them really
cool ones via Howard Stark project
Pegasus in the joint dark energy
research facility that was the New
Avengers base so we got to break it down
we're still doing that Red Dead
Redemption or spider-man ps4 game
giveaway all you have to do to enter
that is be a subscriber and leave a
Marvel related comment on the video I'll
name a new winner at the end of this the
biggest new one here is the Rock the
Vote early 90s Easter Egg so this is a
bit of a Howard Stark connection via the
joint dark energy facility Exodus
Goliath and Pegasus Easter eggs if
you're not a child of the 80s of the 90s
there was this MTV thing called Rock the
Vote that they did to try and get young
people to go out and vote during
corresponding elections they did it for
the 92 election in the 96 election the
reason why this actually dates the
Captain Marvel movie or at least gets
close to what the actual data is during
the movie is because these green posters
were used closer to the 92 election so
even though this doesn't tell you the
exact date during the movie we all
wondered like if it was going to be mid
90s late 90s early 90s the green posters
let you know that it's early 90s so it's
either right before or right after the
92 election so that's why you may hear
people talking on social media about
Captain Marvel being set during 1991 the
reason why 1991 is so important is
because that's the year that Winter
Soldier killed
Iron Man's parents that was during
December 1991
[Music]
so it's totally possible - this is
happening in the events leading up to
that 1991 election in a couple months
after this moment here
Winter Soldier Kills Howard Stark in
Moorea Stark the connection to the
Pegasus Exodus and Goliath Ironman
Easter egg from that deleted Iron Man
scene from Iron Man 2 was because at the
time shield liked the proto version of
shield as you saw during that ant-man at
the wasp flashback had just started to
study what was going on with the
tesseract
so they'd had it for a while Howard
Stark got his hands on it and they were
trying to find a way to use it to create
a limitless source of energy they sort
of picked up on that during the Avengers
movie but that had actually been
happening for a long time and it started
with Howard Stark so one you have to
kind of laugh about the fact that he
went down to the bottom of the ocean to
retrieve the tesseract but they didn't
bother to try and go find Captain
America and unthaw him till many many
years later that was probably because
they thought that he was dead so they
didn't go bothered and look for him they
just assumed that he was gone so you
have Howard Stark working at this joint
dark energy facility trying to find
alternative energy sources alien energy
sources was really what was going on but
they were just calling it dark energy
but you have people like Captain Marvel
come in probably inspiring some of the
direction of their research so even
though Nick Fury gave Iron Man that big
speech about other heroes being out
there at the time you know even though
Captain America is the first Avenger
Captain Marvel is one of the first MCU
heroes that he's actually worked with
it's just that he'd never told Captain
America or any of these other people
about her the other really cool thing
about that new element that Iron Man was
creating during that Iron Man 2 montage
is is that it's based on an idea that
Howard Stark came up with after studying
the tesseract having a moment of
inspiration about the idea for a new
element that Tony then perfected and
turned into his new arc reactors so
Tony's new arc reactor is derived from
infinity stone technology so if you ever
wondered why he's so powerful he's been
using fractional infinity stone energy
at this whole time which makes sense you
know why he would make a character so
powerful so it's not like he has a
limitless energy they never quite fully
achieved that but it's functionally
limitless so it's just another way to
make Iron Man seem that much cooler
because yes it's a new element and
that's what we were mostly focused on
during that moment but this is all based
on research that his father did after
studying the tesseract trying to turn it
into a limitless energy source so this
funny Rock the Vote promo connects all
these different Easter eggs from The
Avengers movie with the tesseract from
Howard Stark in the flashbacks from Iron
Man 2 and Iron Man's arc reactors
there's also a very not-safe-for-work
easter egg that's been etched onto the
pay phone here if you zoom in really
close you can actually see a hotline
number that used to point to the Suite
Life of Zack & Cody which used to be a
Disney Channel TV show that stars Cole
Sprouse from Riverdale and his twin
brother you call the hotline you get a
message that says thank you for calling
ABC the number you have reached is
fictional non-working number used for
motion picture and television
productions it's normal for those
numbers to get cold after an episode
airs so ABC and other networks typically
headed off at the past so it was just
one of those funny things where you see
a number of flash on TV you try to call
it and you actually do get a real
message from it but the thing is that
that TV show was a long time ago and the
Disney Channel has since stopped paying
for that number it is now owned by a sex
hotline so somehow the easter egg makes
this scene even funnier where Captain
Marvel sitting there looking like she's
getting ready to call a sex hotline it's
1 806 589-4030 to be a little more
active on social media not just because
there's an election but because we're
getting closer to the Thanksgiving
holiday season in that Avengers 4
trailer drop and more Captain Marvel
trailers not to be forgotten but a
spider-man far from home trailer
Tom Holland has been much more active on
his social media accounts talking about
spider-man related stuff posting behind
the scenes pictures from far from home
and that's usually just Q that they're
ramping up to drop another trailer and
it's a no brainer that Sony would try to
piggyback on Avengers 4
by trying to release their spider-man
far from home trailer within a short
time span of when Marvel drops the
Avengers 4 trailer like remember how you
were all going crazy just a little while
ago well here's some more so just
remember the way they marketed Black
Panther and Infinity Ward during
November in December last year it'll be
the same basic situation with Captain
Marvel spider-man far from home in
Avengers 4 do not be surprised if Tom
Holland and Mark Ruffalo have some
planned accidental spoilers like
remember when he revealed the title
revelations coming out this weekend
about spider-man - I don't know much
about it I'm a little confused because
I've died so I don't really know how it
all comes into play but I do know is
I've got the new script I'm super
excited to read it and it's gonna be
great so yeah it's fire man soon let's
do this just expect him to do something
like that within the next month or so
they have spider-man into the
spider-verse coming up so I was
expecting them to attach a trailer to
that but they might drop it a little bit
sooner than that if you spotted any
other cool Easter eggs in this promo
that I didn't include in the video just
write them in the comments below
congratulations Ryan McClelland you're
the giveaway winner for my last big
Marvel video please email me on the
about page of my channel so I can get
your contact details click here to watch
Sebastian Stan talk about a brand new
Avengers 4 scene and click here for that
spider-man black costume Infinity Ward
deleted scene thank you so much for
watching everybody stay awesome I'll see
you guys tonight
[Music]